rely on the data and it's not anecdotal
it's not political
it's not an opinion and we also started
something called the surgeon
flex uh public health system management
uh which is something we're going to be
implementing uh
in an increased way today surge in flex
is not the most creative name but what
it says is we
surge and we flex
the hospital system in the state
we start with 54 000 hospital beds
statewide
we can then mandate by the department of
health
dr howard zucker to my left jim milatris
to his left
gareth rhodes to my far right melissa de
rosa to my right you know
uh dr zucker and melissa you've worked
with them but
dr zucker can order a 50 increase in
beds
which we've done before
dr zucker can order no elective
surgeries
which we have done before and we can
create
field hospital beds which we've done
before we can create several thousand
field hospital beds
so when you look at our hospital
capacity we start with 54 000 beds you
can increase it by 50 percent
takes you to 75 000 total bed capacity
uh roughly 35 000 of those beds are now
occupied
if you cancel elective surgery
we estimate that you reduce the number
of occupied beds by about half
that takes us to a total system capacity
of about 58
000 beds for covet patients
today we have 4 600 hospitalized so
that gives you a range of the capacity
for the system
we can also add 5 000 additional field
hospital beds
that would be from my point of view the
last
resource we did that
uh the jacob javits center for example
we did two thousand beds
uh dr fauci it looked like a field
hospital
in an army you just saw an ocean
of of cots and i just hope
we never have to get to that point today
the department of health is going to
issue an order saying
hospitals have to increase their bed
capacity 25 percent
they can we can issue up to 50
they can do that physically but we're
only going to go to 25
because we don't have a capacity
criticality
at this moment we are aware of
staff resources the staff
comes into this stressed right they had
you want to talk about a long
year nurses doctors hospital workers
1199 they had the longest
year of anyone
so they come into this stress we're
going to ask
retired doctors and nurses
to sign up and we will automatically
re-register in
them in the state without cost we
believe we can get about another 20
000 nurses and doctors uh from this
mechanism and then the flex on the
surgeon flex is we have 215 hospitals
what happened in the spring
interestingly
was not that the system was overwhelmed
individual
hospitals got overwhelmed
and the individual hospitals did not
have the capacity
to balance patients frankly this was an
education for me
so your public hospital systems and
let's say you have a public
hospital system that had 10 hospitals
one hospital gets overwhelmed they did
not
have the capacity to balance those
patients among their other nine
hospitals
right so even in the public systems
uh before somebody walked into one
hospital that was already overburdened
they didn't say
hold on i'm gonna put you in a
ambulance and drive you to my sister
hospital that has less volume
what our flex says is those hospitals
have to flex patient load and
share it first within their system
we also shift patient load
among private hospitals which was
frankly
more unorthodox right you're gonna go to
nyu langone
you think you're going to nyu langone
uh what we say in the flux is if nyu
langone
is filled or at capacity we're going to
transfer
you to mount sinai or another hospital
and then we actually have the capacity
to
shift between public and private systems
none of this has been done before was
highly disruptive for the hospital
management system
but we started in it in the spring
it went fine enough and uh
we now have had more experience in it
we've started the flex
management system where every night
we get an inventory from every hospital
doctor
red zone what is critical hospital
capacity
our formula is if your seven
day average shows
that within three weeks
you will hit critical hospital capacity
we close you down so
if your seven day average says if that
continues for three weeks
you're going to hit critical hospital
capacity we close you down we want that
three week
buffer and then we call critical
90 of your hospital capacity
so a little complicated if your seven
day average
says if it continues for three weeks
you're going to hit 90 percent of your
hospital capacity
close down cdc
changed their guidance on friday
some have been critical about the
changing guidance from cdc
i'm not i believe as the facts
change your opinion changes uh
as the facts change your strategy should
change
i don't have a problem with that but
they offered additional guidance on
indoor dining
especially and we're going to follow
their guidance
uh if after five days
we haven't seen a stabilization in a
region's
hospital rate we're going to clamp down
on indoor dining
five days if the hospitalization rate
doesn't
stabilize in new york city we're going
to close indoor dining we're now at 25
in new york city uh in the rest of the
state
any region where the hospitalization
rate doesn't stabilize
then our 50 capacity into a dining we're
going to go to 25
we have zones that are called orange
zones where it's already closed
that wouldn't apply here bottom line for
us
i see it as hospital capacity
versus vaccination critical mass
i think that's the ultimate bottom line
can your hospitals
handle the increase
until you start to see a reduction
from the vaccinations on the hospital
capacity do everything you can do to
slow the spread
and then at the same time accelerate the
vaccines
the frustrations we're seeing here we
estimate over 70
of the spread is coming from small
gatherings
uh and that's a problem we're going to
go through the holiday season i think
there's going to be more small
gatherings
i've been talking until i'm blue in the
face about
the apparent safety of being at home the
apparent
safety of being with your family but
that can be misleading
your brother your sister your mother can
love you but they can still infect you
i know you think you're sitting in your
living room and you're safe
but your living room is not really a
safe zone
uh this isn't a political question trump
cdc
and the biden advisors all agree on the
small gathering guidance
but it's about personal responsibility
and community concern and i'm telling
you compliance is a major issue
for us here uh i'm also frustrated that
we
see uh polls that suggest a high percent
of americans
are not ready to take this vaccine
49 percent nationwide
bigger problem in the black community
57 say they're not ready to take the
vaccine
but 75
to 80 percent uh needs to be vaccinated
to hit critical mass
on the vaccination and that's a problem
if you have 50 saying i'm not taking it
but we have to hit
75 to 80. the good news
is new york still
has one of the lowest positivity rates
in the nation
only maine vermont hawaii are lower than
we are
and maine vermont hawaii beautiful
states but
different than new york they don't have
the cities they don't have the density
etc uh so for us to be down that low
uh is really uh good news as a matter of
fact
our worst region our highest
region in terms of positivity
is still lower than 41 states
so in it's tricky because
relative to everyone else we're doing
well
but the real question is uh
it's not a relative contest at the end
of the day it's
how you're doing in your state
so to recap we're going to monitor the
hospital capacity
uh if it doesn't stabilize
we're going to reduce the indoor dining
restrictions we go to zero new york st
state 25 percent everywhere else
we close down if you hit critical
hospital capacity
we're implementing the surge in flex
we're going to add 25
additional hospital beds renew the
registration for nurses and doctors to
get us a backup staff pool
continue to caution on the small spread
and at the same time we are gearing up
to have the most efficient most
effective most
fair uh vaccination program
in the country reaching out to the black
community
latinos undocumented to make sure that
it's fair
so a couple of questions for you dr
fauci
that's what we're doing in general uh
your opinion has always been valuable to
us
the holiday spread i think it continues
through christmas hanukkah etc
uh trying to guess and i know it's a
guess
when we could see a peak
to this holiday spread
is it after new year's is it january
mid-january
uh do you have any uh any guests
educated point about that and again
thank you very very much for being with
us
well thank you very thank you very much
governor for giving me the opportunity
to uh
listen to what i found to be a very
interesting
plan that you have for new york it seems
really sound and you have a lot of
um you know backup contingencies which i
like
so you're not going to get caught
shorthanded on this i'm i'm certain
um so thank you for that with regard to
the issue of the
holiday spread and the peaks they're
going to be superimposed upon each other
so
you would expect the full blunt
of the travel and the family setting
gatherings with friends that you alluded
to as being
a problem you'd expect that the effect
of the thanksgiving surge would be
probably another week and a week and a
half from now
because it's usually two and a half
weeks
from the time of the event the problem
is that's going to come right
up to the beginning of the christmas
hanukkah
potential surge so you have a surge upon
a surge
and then before you can handle that more
people are going to travel over
christmas
they're going to have more of those
family and friends
gatherings that you accurately said
are an issue so if those two things
happen and we don't
mitigate well we don't listen to the
public health
measures that we need to follow that we
could start to see
things really get bad in the middle of
january so i think
not only for new york state but for any
state or city
that is facing similar problems without
substantial mitigation
the middle of january can be a really
dark time for us
but as you said in your presentation
governor
there are some things that we can do to
mitigate against that
i think particularly the appreciation
that it's such a natural thing to think
when i have family and friends over for
the holidays
christmas and hanukkah you get indoors
you take your mask off because you're
eating and drinking
and you don't realize that there may be
somebody that you know
that you love that's a friend that's a
family member
who is perfectly well with no symptoms
and yet they got infected in the
community
and brought it into that small gathering
that you're now having in your home
so that's the reason why i want to
underscore what you said
that's one of the issues but bottom line
for your first question
mid-january is probably going to be the
bad time
the small spread family spread living
room spread
we call it living room spread here
like 16 states have done an order of no
more than 10 in
a home the cdc guidance
that's president trump cdc says
no more than 10 some states have gone to
no more than eight
people uh compliance is very low
on that do you think that is a
sound rule that no more than 10 in the
home
uh governor i think that's a very sound
rule
uh and i and i feel you know 10 may even
be a
a bit too much it's not only the number
governor but it's the people who might
be coming in from out of town
you mentioned in your presentation how
you don't want somebody
who's from new york who wants to go to a
restaurant that's closed in new york
they go to new jersey
and then they come back they've traveled
back and forth in addition to the
absolute number of the people in a home
for a gathering or a social
setting you want to make sure you don't
get people who just got off
an airport or a plane or a train and
came in from
florida or came in from wherever that's
even more risky
than the absolute number so not only the
number of 10 seems reasonable
but make sure that when people come in
that they're not people you have no idea
where they've been or who they've been
exposed to i mean you want to be
friendly you want to be collegial
but you really got to be careful about
that yeah
no you're so right doctor and the the
practice the practical implications are
so
difficult uh as i mentioned at her
birthday yesterday
one of my daughters uh who wasn't with
me who wanted to come up she had a
quarantine
before she could come to my birthday you
know
so you want to go travel and see someone
it's not just that weekend it's the
whole quarantining process
before and in this state we have very
strict regulations of when you come
in what you have to do uh
on the vaccinations looking ahead
uh 75-80 percent is going to be very
hard to reach
new yorkers are tuned in and we're going
to be very aggressive on public
education outreach etc
uh but what does your crystal ball say
uh when would when is 7580
even feasible you know i hear anywhere
from uh may june july
august september uh what would you guess
there which is when it's really over
right when the vaccination hits critical
mass
yeah when you have 75 80 percent of the
people vaccinated you have an
umbrella of protection over the
community
that the level of community spread will
be really
really very low the virus will not have
any place to go
it's almost metaphorically if you think
the virus is looking for some victims
when most of the people are protected
the virus has a hard time
latching on to someone when that happens
governor is going to be entirely
dependent upon how well we do
how well i do you do your health
officials
in getting the message out of why it's
so important
for people to get vaccinated because if
50
of the people get vaccinated then we
don't have that that
umbrella of immunity over us but let's
say it works out well
let me answer your question specifically
and we do a really good job of
convincing people
uh between now and the end of december
you would likely get a substantial
proportion
of health care providers and people in
your nursing homes
as you get into january you'll get the
second level
and then february 3rd i would think by
the time you get
to the beginning of april you'll start
getting people
who have no high priority just a normal
man and woman new yorker in the street
who's well
has no underlying conditions if we get
them vaccinated
in a full court press get get them
really going
and you do that through april may
and june by the time you get to the
summer because remember it's a prime
boost which means you get vaccinated
today you get a boost 28 days from now
and then seven to ten days following
that
you're optimally protected even though
you could get some protection
even after the first shot but optimally
it's within
seven to ten days following the second
shot if we do that well by the time we
get
into the core of the summer and get to
the end of the summer and into the start
of the third
quarter of 2021 we should be in good
shape
that's what i'm hoping for and that's
the reason why it's so important
to extend ourselves out to the community
particularly to the
black african-american latino the people
are undocumented
the people who we really need to get
vaccinated
well doc i couldn't agree with you more
than that i'm pushing the uh
the congress right now new york uh
look i think it would be discriminatory
not to understand the situation that
exists
with the black and latino population who
by the way
had blacks had twice the death rate of
whites latinos had one and a half times
the
death rate of whites higher infection
rate
higher percentage of essential workers
we're going to need a whole
effort just to educate and outreach and
get into public housing
and communicate with their communities
because otherwise
i don't think you know they're not going
to flock to the local
walmart or kmart or
walgreens to take this vaccine i think
we're going to need an
affirmative effort to do that
let me ask you this our school
positivity rate
is amazingly low
uh even in communities that have higher
spread we're seeing much much lower
infection rates in schools uh
it's almost a universal statement that
the school is the safest
place to be in the community
does that surprise you you know it
originally did surprise me because we
were always concerned if you look at the
influenza model
the issue is the kids are in school they
get infected they come home and they
infect
their parents and their relatives we're
not finding that
with this coronavirus in fact to our
i think real positive spin-off of this
is the realization that schools appear
to be a place where
the positivity just like you all are
seeing it
in new york the whole state including
new york city
you're not alone we're seeing that in
other parts of the country
that the that the test positivity in
school
is actually really low which is really a
good thing
which is one of the reasons why you know
when we were talking about
what the best strategy would be we would
say something like you know close the
bars keep the schools open
is the best thing to do so long as
you subsidize and help the restaurateurs
and the bar owners so that they don't go
down
and essentially crash because of the
economic strain but if we can
keep those things under control
subsidize those people
as well as keep the schools open we'd be
in good shape
yeah and i think you're exactly right
the
cdc says uh more restrictions on indoor
dining which i understand
and again changing positions when facts
change is intelligent
you know people say well remain
consistent i'm not going to be
consistent
if the facts are inconsistent and if i
see a different situation i'm gonna
change my opinion
uh but uh the congress washington also
has to understand those bars those
restaurants they need financial
assistance
because this has been a long year
and they have bills to pay so you can't
tell them
we have to close you down without saying
here's the economic reality and we're
going to help
dr on the question of the s
this state's infection rate versus
other states where lower than all states
besides
vermont maine hawaii does that
surprise you and how do you explain that
you know i have to say being a new
yorker governor it doesn't surprise me
uh you you guys as you and i have
discussed on many phone calls that we've
had
you got hit you know with a with a
sucker punch
right from the beginning when when the
cases came in from europe and
the northeastern corridor particularly
new york state particularly the
metropolitan area got hit
really really badly you recovered from
that
was after you got hit badly your
baseline
level went way way down and very very
low
and then you did things which were the
appropriate way
to avoid getting resurging so the bad
news
and it's painful for me to see it from a
distance
to my place of birth but you guys got
really slammed
and then you rebounded and you rebounded
in a way
that you kept your test positivity low
because you did the prudent things that
you need to do
and my was following it from here in
washington
and i was seeing that whenever it looked
like things were getting a little out of
hand you tightened the rope a little bit
and then when things went back you eased
up a little bit so i'm not surprised
that your infection rate is really low
because i think you were doing the right
things after you had a really
serious hit in the beginning when you
were there in the late
winter early spring
doctor on this education of the
population of both the small spreads and
even more now the vaccine take the
vaccine it's safe
i think that's going to be difficult to
do i think you have tremendous
credibility not just across the country
but across this state
and i think your voice on saying that
the vaccines
are safe would be important i said that
as soon as
the vaccine is deemed ready and safe
i'll be the first one to take a vaccine
maybe we enlist you i'll do it with you
we'll do an ad
telling new yorkers it's safe to take
the vaccine
to uh to you know put us together we're
like the
modern-day uh de niro and pacino you can
be which whenever
whichever you want you can be the de
niro pacino
who do you want to be de niro or pacino
which one do you want to write
i love them one of the other if they
want i don't want to hurt the feelings
the politician all right last question i
know you're down in washington you're
doing great duty but i know you miss
new york uh what we want to figure out
what to send you from
christmas for christmas what food do you
miss the most that you can't get down
there
that you could get if you were back here
in new york and brooklyn
you know governor whenever i need some
comfort food and i dream back of my days
in the benson her section of brooklyn
the thing that comes to my mind are two
things a nice
nathan hot dog and a really steaming
pastrami sandwich
that would be really great all right so
no cannolis no meatballs
no nathan's out there
welcome i'll take them all
all right done doctor thank you so much
for everything you've done
for this country god bless you god bless
you it's uh
you know this was a moment that we
really got to see what people were made
of
uh when the pressure's on you see the
weaknesses and you see the strength
and the pressure was on and uh
it forged you into a rock
that really stabilized this nation so
god bless you for what you did doctor
and i know what to get you for christmas
send a bill to christopher
thank you very much god bless you doctor
be safe yeah
you too thanks an awful lot appreciate
it thank you
thank you okay
italian guy is for a nathan's hot dog
and a pastrami sandwich you can't figure
out anything anymore
i mean if you had to bet what he was
going to ask for from bensonhurst
anyway questions governor could indoor
dining shut down
as soon as this wednesday i believe new
york city's tested about three percent
for eight days straight
the first there are different numbers
right
uh the state
sets the policy the state uses the state
numbers
local governments have different numbers
different configurations
that's nice but we use the state numbers
uh cdc came out with additional guidance
on friday
um and we're going to follow that
additional guidance which is basically
more caution for indoor dining
we're going to watch the hospitalization
rate over the next
five days if that hospitalization rate
doesn't stabilize
which frankly i don't expect it to i
think dr fauci is right
you're seeing the thanksgiving wave is
just starting to break and then the
christmas hanukkah kwanzaa wave
is going to start so i don't see it
uh new yorkers could change it
right because it's all a function of
behavior
but if the hospitalization rate doesn't
stabilize
over the next five days then we'll go
from 25 to zero
in new york 50 to 25.
outside of new york city besides the
orange zones which are already at zero
would that take effect the next day
um that would take effect
within a couple of days we'd give the
restaurants a couple of days to
uh reorient something should we expect
it would take effect
the following monday then if cases
consider hospitalization say
monday if the rate doesn't stabilize
and again look forget the indoor dining
let's look at the big picture we are
looking
at hospitalization capacity
and if we don't get the rate
under control and you are going to
overwhelm your hospitals
we will have to go back to shutdown
there are certain absolutes okay
uh what is the absolute here
you cannot overwhelm your hospitals you
can't be
italy you can't overwhelm your hospitals
if you are at a rate that is going to
overwhelm your hospitals you must shut
down
not just indoor dining shut down
only essential businesses
oh we don't want to do that again then
change your behavior
but if we don't change our behavior that
is the
absolute reality of the situation
how can you talk about closed down again
that was terrible because it's the truth
it's the truth i started this telling
people the truth i'm going to end it
telling people the truth
you cannot overwhelm the hospitals
no state is better than we are
at managing the hospital system by the
way no other state
does that surge in flex plan
so we will manage the hospital system as
well as it can be managed
but if you're going to overwhelm the
hospital system
then we have no choice
but to go to close down dr fauci
just to get the full parameter here
right
uh because we look at these day-to-day
but it's not really day-to-day look
between now
and vaccination effectiveness
that's the window we're looking at we're
looking at december january february
march
april uh and then
april as dr fauci said you start to do
the general population
between now and then slow
the rate of spread slow the rate of
hospitalization
if you overwhelm the hospital capacity
you will have to go back
to shut down there are no options
that's not discretionary that's not
uh well maybe there's an alternative
you can't overwhelm the hospital system
overwhelming the hospital system
means people die on a gurney
in a hallway and the life
you could have saved you can't save
because you don't have the staff you
don't have the doctor you don't have the
nurse
and people die unnecessarily
those are the do you absolutes the
misconceptions
about the vaccine uh people have said to
me
i don't want to get injected and then
get sick
and get the coping virus or they feel
it's being rushed
and they don't feel it's going to be
stable or viable so how do you address
people you know some of these things may
be inaccurate but
how do you address these misconceptions
new yorkers
are a skeptical bunch
i don't blame them i'm a new yorker born
and bred
i'm skeptical i am
take a vaccine uh you take the vaccine
first
okay and you tell me how it goes and
then you call me
and then i'll take the vaccine that's
what i say when you say to me i should
take the vaccine
all the polls say it it's a real problem
a
you have people who think people you
have many people who think the
vaccine was rushed for political reasons
by the trump administration
uh that trump interfered with the
medical approval process
that is a real factor
true not true doesn't matter that's a
real factor
b you're asking people to take a vaccine
and older people to take a vaccine
that's frightening uh and
the doctors will say you know there
could be side effects and we'll do more
testing six months eight months times
and this whole situation on culvert has
been changing all the time now there are
long term
effects once covered was over it was
over now maybe it's not over
i get it it is going to be
uh a public education campaign
with people with credibility
uh and people who are willing to lead
by example i would not ask
new yorkers to take any vaccine that i
would not take myself
would you take one publicly i will
publicly take the vaccine
also on that trump skepticism we
added a new york state review
panel headed by a noble laureate
so you're going to have the trump
approval the new york state panel
as a second approval in case you were
nervous about trump
second approval and then
dr fauci will say take it i will say
take it
other leading health experts will take
it
and answering that new york's question
new yorker's question
it's safe okay if it's so safe put the
needle in your
arm and let me know how it feels
and i'm willing to do that zach talk
about the situation in staten island as
you know they were gathering protests
they've arrested the bar
owner there a couple of times uh kind of
an ugly incident we heard about where he
may have run over
a sheriff with his car what do you make
of what's going on out there
is there some sort of aversion
culturally to
mask wearing and you know social
i think this act i think it is a very
uh troubling and disturbing situation
uh i think people are frustrated
people are anxious people's lives have
been disrupted
because they have been it's not just
coveted fatigue
it's cold with exhaustion
it's covered anxiety
it's covered anger
i understand that i understand that
uh but we have to deal with it but what
happened in staten island
there were certain first of all staten
island
has gone from the lowest death rate
in the city to the highest
death rate in the city
so all these local officials
who are saying that's right
we don't have to do any of this forget
this
don't comply freedom
yeah freedom to die congratulations
you went from the lowest death rate
in the city of new york to the highest
death rate in the city of new york
you gave great advice to your people
more of them died
a new york value was
for a couple of primary new york values
one of them was you don't
assault a police officer
you don't assault a police officer
they are defending a person
who drove his car into
a law enforcement officer drove
a hundred yards with the law enforcement
officer
clinging to the hood for his life
and that's who their champion
that's who their champion
someone who attacked a law enforcement
officer
you don't attack the nypd
you don't do it they're putting their
life on the line
you don't attack them you don't attack a
law enforce
enforcement officer who's doing his or
her job
and when you have someone who drives
their car
into someone could have killed him
hospitalizes him how dare you
what signal are you sending
when you glamorize that type of behavior
yeah that's right run over the police
what what
who says that who's ever
said that well we're not going to comply
congratulations you represented your
people well
more have died go back and campaign
we went from the lowest death rate in
the city
to the highest death rate in the city
because of my advice
congratulations congratulations
no it's repugnant to the values
of any real new yorker
you never assault a police officer
tough guy drives his car
into a police officer no that's
disgusting
and a coward governor we currently have
a series of orange zones across the
state that were set up using
positivity rates are those not going to
be altered or eliminated
based on your new model using hospital
metrics
the the cdc
guidance targets indoor dining
which we're following the orange zone
the only the real difference between a
yellow zone and an orange zone
is the indoor dining uh and gyms and
salons
gyms and salons on the numbers we have
so many protocols on the gyms and salons
they're not
major spreaders on the numbers it is
about indo-dining this will
uh this is on top of
the uh orange regulation so this would
supersede so in other words
you'd close indoor dining in new york
city in five days which is what would
happen in an
orange zone so my question to you is
this you've said that you would
it's a hospitalization race don't
stabilize you would close
indoor dining totally in new york city
and the rest of the state would go
to 25 from 50 to 25 except in the orange
zones where it's already closed yes
ma'am
a number that the hospitalizations that
would trigger
your decision to do that and also so are
you
and i want to make sure i understand
this you're also saying that this is
just indoor dining
and barbs you're not going to go after
gyms hair salons
beauty parlors nail salons this is just
indoor tiny
the cdc has targeted the indoor dining
as a spreader and this is indoor dining
stabilization
is stabilization stabilization
stable where you are now
stabilized instead of going up right so
this
is stabilization this is increasing
if your hospitalization rate now
is whatever it is let's say it's four
percent
uh instead of going from four to five
you'd have to stay
at four and stabilize so it's no longer
increasing right now it's increasing
in new york city and it goes up in
buffalo
region by region so if it's stable in
new york city
then uh we're fine if it
doesn't stabilize and continues to
increase
which it has been doing which i expect
it to continue to do
unless people change their behavior uh
then you would have a close down in new
york city
in other words to be stable in new york
city you don't invoke the indo-dining
rule in new york city or say it's stable
in
westchester or long island you don't
invoke it there but you would bulk it in
places where
there's instability in the hospital
system it's
region by region that region's rate
would have to be stable
am i asking is no that's correct so
marsha we're looking at all of them by
regions that we've broken the state out
into the 10 different regions
and when you're looking at
hospitalizations it's important to look
at it regionally because for example in
new york city if you live in brooklyn
you could go to a manhattan hospital
right so the hospital system
acts more together regionally so the
governor saying is
we're looking at this region by region
and if the hospitalization rates in each
region don't stabilize
if you're a region outside of new york
city you'd go from 50 to 25
they have less crowding and density in
new york city 25
to closure
the sanctions so in other words say it
continues to go up
in a region but then it stabilizes would
you then bring back indoor dining
i don't know good question i don't know
how would you if you
ever how would you uh when would you
undo restrictions yeah you would have to
see a stabilization or a reduction
frankly we're looking at the opposite
situation
we are looking at continued increases
from now through mid-january
uh did dr couchy just say mid-january or
late january
mid-january because uh
just just think about it right you're
still dealing with thanksgiving
thanksgiving runs right into
uh christmas kwanzaa hanukkah runs right
into new year's eve
new year's day that's why i said when we
got to thanksgiving
remember i said it's not thanksgiving
it's
the beginning of 37 days of a holiday
season
and if you don't radically change your
behavior
which is very hard during the holiday
season you know
i get it but you will see an increase
through that holiday season through
new year's eve new year's day
give it another two and a half weeks and
then you'll feel
fill feel the full increase
so i can see an increase right through
mid-january
and then well what starts to decrease it
hopefully you stabilize mid-january
and then the vaccine starts to kick in
but you know this is a road nobody's
been down
but that's if you're crystal balling it
and that's what i heard dr fauci to say
in a lot of the projections to say
dr circuit is that yes absolutely
correct your crystal ball do you want to
give us a date
in january january i made it that way
i'm sorry closing down could happen as
early as monday as early
as monday if the hospitalization rate
doesn't stabilize and again
marshall we are in control of this this
is nothing
predestined and
we're talking about life and the covet
increase like it's a fair complete
it is not a fair complete uh
so just change your behavior
change your behavior and get past
this mistaken impression
that i am home and my home is safe
i'm with my family and my family is safe
50 of the spread is
asymptomatic spread so
your sister who loves you
can infect you and she will say
afterwards i didn't even know i had it
i felt fine i didn't sneeze i didn't
cough i didn't do anything i would have
never done that
on purpose and she'll be telling you the
truth
50 percent asymptomatic spread
and that's why the cdc just changed
their guidance
literally on
said that it's friday not a faded
complaint
yet you also say it's inevitable
and you don't want people dying on
gurneys
so it seems like if it's inevitable
why wait no it is not inevitable earlier
inevitable i think it is
if i use the word inevitable
uh let me change that word i believe
that is what is going to happen
i believe you're going to see
thanksgiving run into christmas run at
donica run into new year's and you're
going to see this
i believe that and that's what most
experts believe that's what dr fauci
just said
but it doesn't have to be that
you could see new yorkers change their
behavior
and be more careful and
flatten and you don't have the increase
that is a possibility
i don't think it's a probability because
i've been sitting here for the past
month saying please please please
but it it is a possibility
uh worst case scenario
the number keeps going up and it gets
so high that you
endanger overwhelming the hospitals
then we have to hit pause
and go back to closure or we don't want
to do that we don't want to do
that then you have to alter your
behavior to reduce the spread
do i believe between now and
five days we'll see a stabilization rate
in new york city i would be
pleasantly surprised i don't think
it is probable but it is possible
do i think we hit
hospitals at hospitalization
criticality and have to close down
i pray no i hope no
i hope new yorkers get it before we get
there
i'm going to be i'm restarting the
briefings monday wednesday friday
i'm going to show you the number every
day say here's the number
another two points and we close here's
the number
another one point when we close here's
the number another half point then we
close
so uh it's it's
up to new yorkers well why do i have any
hope
look at our infection rate
vermont main hawaii new york
that's all new york intelligence
and unity and community and toughness
and love defying
the nation defying the nation
that's what new york did on the
infection rate
so it's possible
um so in the spring the pandemic was
pretty much defined by shortages
you're running out of ventilators you're
running out of beds there's always been
some things missing and
what healthcare workers have told me is
they worry that they're the neck
shortage
um there are fewer nurses i'm talking to
a lot of nurses who said they're
retiring
they have ptsd from you know what
they've experienced
and i wanted to know you know because
we're going to see
the increase in debt capacity are you
concerned about that there's not going
to be enough nurses or other
professionals to staff it and is there
anything
in your power that you can do to kind of
assist beyond the medical reserve
yeah let me give you the ups and the
downs uh
at our surge in the spring we had 18
000 people with covet in hospital beds
let's say 19 was our high number okay
we now have about 4 000 people in
hospital beds
19 was the high number and then 19 was
the high number
in a circumstance that
was reminiscent of an apocalypse
right it was nineteen thousand
dr faucio forget his word he didn't say
we've got
ambushed sucker punch
because what happened to us was we had
that spread from europe as the doctor
said and nobody
told us i believe it was federal
negligence
or it was frankly the federal government
lying to us
but the virus spread to europe infected
europeans were coming here
there was no european travel ban till
march 16th
so we went from zero to a hundred
uh overnight
i don't believe we ever have that
situation of stress
again um i don't believe we get to that
number of people in the hospitals
again and
we didn't have a staff shortage at that
time we had
tremendous staff stress
uh fatigue etc
i believe we're going to be in a more
controlled circumstance this time
with less overall stress
i get the ptsd phenomenon
uh i think about the decisions i make
from a ptsd point of view i think about
the advice i get from my staff
by the way who i think have ptsd from
the situation
uh and when you're looking at the
numbers are you looking at the numbers
or are you
looking at the numbers with this filter
of ptsd from the spring right
um but we didn't really have a staff
shortage we just
were brutal on the staff if you will
uh we're going to bring up the reserves
i think we're going to have
if i had to estimate uh tens of
thousands
of retirees who will come help
the system and if we balance it better
remember what happened last time and i
talked to dr fauci about this before
but you guys have to appreciate this
the system wasn't overwhelmed
individual hospitals were overwhelmed
and the individual hospital was a silo
so they showed up at one hospital that
by the way had a sister hospital over
here and a sister hospital over here
and rather than sending people to the
sister hospitals
they just got sat there and got
overwhelmed
why well that's how we operate people
come from our community to our hospital
and we accept them
i know but this is a different situation
the volume is too high
you have to uh not accept that person
when they come to the door say
i'm sorry zach but there's a hot
an ambulance outside that's going to
drive you to melissa's hospital right
down the block
it's not as good as my hospital
thinks it is but it's not take you to
howard's hospital
it's not as good as my hospital but it's
not bad
but we didn't we didn't
manage the volume because there was no
management system the state doesn't
manage
quickly i remember the press conference
at the java center where mr dowling and
mr askey were there
you're talking about this management
system was that at the point
of like you set it up it was kind of too
late in the hospitals
we're starting to come down from that
wave um and now that this is in full
effect i know northwell's been trying to
um
was talking about how you're doing early
warnings and trying to figure out
which hospitals are more likely to go
overwhelmed so if elm purses slam
you send them to a different hospital
audience instead of you know what the
situation i'm talking about so i was
just hoping to elaborate
more on what the state did earlier on
and how that's going to apply for
you know any other searches moving
forward it was the first time we had
ever seen this situation
and in truth uh
we we are better equipped now
it is still not perfect because
we don't run any of these systems you
know
the h h is a separate system in new york
city it's run by new york city they have
hnh
buddha they have 11 hospitals nine
hospitals 11.
they have 11 hospitals they run 11
hospitals
uh do you really need me
to tell hnh by the way you have 11
hospitals
don't overwhelm one distribute it among
11.
the private hospital system the state
really has no management
we regulate but and what you land on is
nyu langone
and mount sinai is mount sinai
so this is really a new role for us
that's why no other state does it
we just step in and say there's a public
health emergency
and we are now going to oversee the
system
like an oversight capacity
uh but think about it it was just it was
just
extraordinary because this is all
private system basically 215 hospitals
overwhelming majority private and then
you have a couple of public systems
suffolk has a public system new york
city is a public system
erie has a public system who else is a
public system
jim has a couple of
jim's hospitals i'm especially watching
closely
because i don't believe he is a natural
load balancer let's take
one more vaccine the fda is supposed to
uh offer approval as soon as thursday
would the mechanics then be that once
it's approved on thursday it gets
loaded onto trucks airplanes how does it
physically get
to new york and where do you first
anticipate those files
arriving on monday or tuesday it gets
approved
by washington the military
general purna is in charge of
transporting it
they use fedex believe it or not
another company called mckinnon do you
remember the name of that other company
mckesson mckesson
they transport it as soon as the federal
panel
meets our new york panel
has already been talking to the fda
our new york panel will review the fda
while the vaccines are in transport
the new york panel will act assuming
they approve it
the trucks roll we then have the
prioritization of where they go
nursing home nursing home workers within
the health care
workers they're about 700 000 health
care workers
the high risk health care workers
uh and those are the first three
tranches
and uh frankly uh
we're not beyond the first three
tranches which will take
weeks and weeks to get beyond those
first three trunches i have to go to
work
bring it into javits like is there a
center they
they will distribute the feds distribute
wherever we ask them to distribute
and we then have regional distribution
plans from there
thank you very much